Ten years ago exactly,
I was in Afghanistan.
I was covering the war in Afghanistan,
and I witnessed, as a reporter for Al Jazeera,
the amount of suffering and destruction
that emerged out of a war like that.
Then, two years later,
I covered another war -- the war in Iraq.
I was placed at the center of that war
because I was covering the war
from the northern part of Iraq.
And the war ended
with a regime change,
like the one in Afghanistan.
And that regime
that we got rid of
was actually a dictatorship,
an authoritarian regime,
that for decades
created a great sense of paralysis
within the nation, within the people themselves.
However,
the change that came through foreign intervention
created even worse circumstances for the people
and deepened the sense
of paralysis and inferiority
in that part of the world.
For decades,
we have lived under authoritarian regimes --
in the Arab world, in the Middle East.
These regimes
created something within us during this period.
I'm 43 years old right now.
For the last 40 years,
I have seen almost the same faces
for kings and presidents ruling us --
old, aged, authoritarian,
corrupt situations --
regimes that we have seen around us.
And for a moment I was wondering,
are we going to live in order to see
real change happening on the ground,
a change that does not come through foreign intervention,
through the misery of occupation,
through nations invading our land
and deepening the sense of inferiority sometimes?
The Iraqis: yes, they got rid of Saddam Hussein,
but when they saw
their land occupied by foreign forces
they felt very sad,
they felt that their dignity had suffered.
And this is why they revolted.
This is why they did not accept.
And actually other regimes, they told their citizens,
"Would you like to see the situation of Iraq?
Would you like to see civil war, sectarian killing?
Would you like to see destruction?
Would you like to see foreign troops on your land?"
And the people thought for themselves,
"Maybe we should live with
this kind of authoritarian situation that we find ourselves in,
instead of having the second scenario."
That was one of the worst nightmares that we have seen.
For 10 years,
unfortunately we have found ourselves
reporting images of destruction,
images of killing,
of sectarian conflicts,
images of violence,
emerging from a magnificent piece of land,
a region that one day was the source
of civilizations and art and culture
for thousands of years.
Now I am here to tell you
that the future
that we were dreaming for
has eventually arrived.
A new generation,
well-educated,
connected,
inspired by universal values
and a global understanding,
has created a new reality for us.
We have found a new way
to express our feelings
and to express our dreams:
these young people
who have restored self-confidence
in our nations in that part of the world,
who have given us
new meaning for freedom
and empowered us to go down to the streets.
Nothing happened. No violence. Nothing.
Just step out of your house,
raise your voice
and say, "We would like to see the end of the regime."
This is what happened in Tunisia.
Over a few days,
the Tunisian regime that invested billions of dollars
in the security agencies,
billions of dollars
in maintaining, trying to maintain,
its prisons,
collapsed, disappeared,
because of the voices of the public.
People who were inspired to go down to the streets
and to raise their voices,
they tried to kill.
The intelligence agencies wanted to arrest people.
They found something called Facebook.
They found something called Twitter.
They were surprised by all of these kinds of issues.
And they said,
"These kids are misled."
Therefore, they asked their parents
to go down to the streets
and collect them, bring them back home.
This is what they were telling. This is their propaganda.
"Bring these kids home
because they are misled."
But yes,
these youth
who have been inspired
by universal values,
who are idealistic enough
to imagine a magnificent future
and, at the same time, realistic enough
to balance this kind of imagination
and the process leading to it --
not using violence,
not trying to create chaos --
these young people,
they did not go home.
Parents actually went to the streets
and they supported them.
And this is how the revolution was born in Tunisia.
We in Al Jazeera
were banned from Tunisia for years,
and the government did not allow
any Al Jazeera reporter to be there.
But we found that these people in the street,
all of them are our reporters,
feeding our newsroom
with pictures, with videos
and with news.
And suddenly that newsroom in Doha
became a center
that received all this kind of input from ordinary people --
people who are connected and people who have ambition
and who have liberated themselves
from the feeling of inferiority.
And then we took that decision:
We are unrolling the news.
We are going to be the voice for these voiceless people.
We are going to spread the message.
Yes, some of these young people
are connected to the Internet,
but the connectivity in the Arab world
is very little, is very small,
because of many problems that we are suffering from.
But Al Jazeera took the voice from these people
and we amplified [it].
We put it in every sitting room in the Arab world --
and internationally, globally,
through our English channel.
And then people started to feel
that there's something new happening.
And then Zine al-Abidine Ben Ali
decided to leave.
And then Egypt started,
and Hosni Mubarak decided to leave.
And now Libya as you see it.
And then you have Yemen.
And you have many other countries trying to see
and to rediscover that feeling
of, "How do we imagine a future
which is magnificent and peaceful and tolerant?"
I want to tell you something,
that the Internet and connectivity
has created [a] new mindset.
But this mindset
has continued to be faithful
to the soil and to the land
that it emerged from.
And while this was the major difference
between many initiatives before
to create change,
before we thought, and governments told us --
and even sometimes it was true --
that change was imposed on us,
and people rejected that,
because they thought that it is alien to their culture.
Always, we believed
that change will spring from within,
that change should be a reconciliation
with culture, cultural diversity,
with our faith in our tradition
and in our history,
but at the same time,
open to universal values, connected with the world,
tolerant to the outside.
And this is the moment
that is happening right now in the Arab world.
This is the right moment, and this is the actual moment
that we see all of these meanings meet together
and then create the beginning
of this magnificent era
that will emerge from the region.
How did the elite deal with that --
the so-called political elite?
In front of Facebook,
they brought the camels in Tahrir Square.
In front of Al Jazeera,
they started creating tribalism.
And then when they failed,
they started speaking about conspiracies
that emerged from Tel Aviv and Washington
in order to divide the Arab world.
They started telling the West,
"Be aware of Al-Qaeda.
Al-Qaeda is taking over our territories.
These are Islamists
trying to create new Imaras.
Be aware of these people
who [are] coming to you
in order to ruin your great civilization."
Fortunately,
people right now cannot be deceived.
Because this corrupt elite
in that region
has lost even the power of deception.
They could not, and they cannot, imagine
how they could really deal with this reality.
They have lost.
They have been detached
from their people, from the masses,
and now we are seeing them collapsing
one after the other.
Al Jazeera is not
a tool of revolution.
We do not create revolutions.
However,
when something of that magnitude happens,
we are at the center of the coverage.
We were banned from Egypt,
and our correspondents,
some of them were arrested.
But most of our camera people
and our journalists,
they went underground in Egypt -- voluntarily --
to report what happened in Tahrir Square.
For 18 days,
our cameras were broadcasting, live,
the voices of the people in Tahrir Square.
I remember one night
when someone phoned me on my cellphone --
ordinary person who I don't know -- from Tahrir Square.
He told me, "We appeal to you
not to switch off the cameras.
If you switch off the cameras tonight,
there will be a genocide.
You are protecting us
by showing what is happening at Tahrir Square."
I felt the responsibility
to phone our correspondents there
and to phone our newsroom
and to tell them, "Make your best
not to switch off the cameras at night,
because the guys there really feel confident
when someone is reporting their story --
and they feel protected as well."
So we have a chance
to create a new future
in that part of the world.
We have a chance
to go and to think of the future
as something which is open to the world.
Let us not repeat the mistake of Iran,
of [the] Mosaddeq revolution.
Let us free ourselves -- especially in the West --
from thinking about that part of the world
based on oil interest,
or based on interests
of the illusion of stability and security.
The stability and security
of authoritarian regimes
cannot create
but terrorism and violence and destruction.
Let us accept the choice of the people.
Let us not pick and choose
who we would like to rule their future.
The future should be ruled
by people themselves,
even sometimes if they are voices
that might now scare us.
But the values of democracy
and the freedom of choice
that is sweeping the Middle East at this moment in time
is the best opportunity for the world,
for the West and the East,
to see stability and to see security
and to see friendship and to see tolerance
emerging from the Arab world,
rather than the images of violence and terrorism.
Let us support these people.
Let us stand for them.
And let us give up
our narrow selfishness
in order to embrace change,
and in order to celebrate with the people of that region
a great future
and hope and tolerance.
The future has arrived,
and the future is now.
I thank you very much.
(Applause)
Thank you very much.
Chris Anderson: I just have a couple of questions for you.
Thank you for coming here.
How would you characterize the historical significance
of what's happened?
Is this a story-of-the-year, a story-of-the-decade
or something more?
Wadah Khanfar: Actually, this may be the biggest story that we have ever covered.
We have covered many wars.
We have covered a lot of tragedies, a lot of problems,
a lot of conflict zones, a lot of hot spots in the region,
because we were centered at the middle of it.
But this is a story -- it is a great story; it is beautiful.
It is not something that you only cover
because you have to cover a great incident.
You are witnessing change in history.
You are witnessing the birth of a new era.
And this is what the story's all about.
CA: There are a lot of people in the West
who are still skeptical,
or think this may just be an intermediate stage
before much more alarming chaos.
You really believe
that if there are democratic elections in Egypt now,
that a government could emerge
that espouses some of the values you've spoken about so inspiringly?
WK: And people actually,
after the collapse of the Hosni Mubarak regime,
the youth who have organized themselves
in certain groups and councils,
they are guarding the transformation
and they are trying to put it on a track
in order to satisfy
the values of democracy,
but at the same time
also to make it reasonable
and to make it rational,
not to go out of order.
In my opinion, these people are much more wiser
than, not only the political elite,
even the intellectual elite, even opposition leaders
including political parties.
At this moment in time, the youth in the Arab world
are much more wiser
and capable of creating the change
than the old --
including the political and cultural
and ideological
old regimes.
(Applause)
CA: We are not to get involved politically and interfere in that way.
What should people here at TED,
here in the West,
do if they want to connect or make a difference
and they believe in what's happening here?
WK: I think we have discovered a very important issue in the Arab world --
that people care,
people care about this great transformation.
Mohamed Nanabhay who's sitting with us,
the head of Aljazeera.net,
he told me that a 2,500 percent increase
of accessing our website
from various parts of the world.
Fifty percent of it is coming from America.
Because we discovered that people care,
and people would like to know --
they are receiving the stream through our Internet.
Unfortunately in the United States,
we are not covering but Washington D.C. at this moment in time
for Al Jazeera English.
But I can tell you, this is the moment to celebrate
through connecting ourselves
with those people in the street
and expressing our support to them
and expressing this kind of feeling, universal feeling,
of supporting the weak and the oppressed
to create a much better future for all of us.
CA: Well Wadah, a group of members of the TED community,
TEDxCairo,
are meeting as we speak.
They've had some speakers there.
I believe they've heard your talk.
Thank you for inspiring them and for inspiring all of us.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)